was für nachrichten heiter zu werden ich
bin in gewisser weise oppositions modus
ebenfalls was die bundeskanzlerin
anbetrifft und ihre jüngsten gespräch
offensiven mit dem diktator lukaschenko
dem diktator von belarus sie hat zwei
heute im telefon geht in den vergangenen
48 stunden und hat dafür sehr viel
kritik einstecken müssen ich glaube zu
recht man kann sich gegen diplomatische
beziehungen überhaupt nicht während am
ende ist auch gut glaube ich wenn
gesprochen wird aber die art und weise
wie die bundeskanzlerin ihre anrufe
vorbereitet hat in linz die waren
einfach schlecht und haben wieder mal
dazu beigetragen europa zu spalten die
bundeskanzlerin hat auf ihre letzten
meter also wieder mal für zorn gesorgt
für ärger und das ist eigentlich völlig
unnötig wir wissen in europa sind wir
alle gemeinsam sind die länder nur stark
wenn man miteinander spricht gerade wenn
es um diktatoren wie lukaschenko und
putin geht das hat sie nicht gemacht und
da hat sie versandt also ich habe mir
das hin und her durch den kopf gehen
lassen ich hatte denselben impuls ich
habe auch gesagt während einer
erpressung spricht man nicht mit dem
erpresser weil da fühlt sich ermutigt er
kriegt ja irgendein angebot da kommt ja
was deshalb wird ja telefoniert nun habe
ich aber auch gelesen und zwar bei
dieser zeitung bei der wir hier sitzen
welt dass er angerufen hat bei ihr und
nicht sie bei ihm und sie hat dann mit
ihm geredet heute zum zweiten mal
geredet und offenbar geht es darum in
der sache dass ein weg gefunden wird ein
teil der flüchtlinge zunächst mal
vielleicht dann auch alle
zurückzufliegen in den irak oder in die
herkunftsländer und zieht ist zum abflug
dort einigermaßen menschenwürdig in
belarus unterzubringen aber jetzt aber
mit einem sehr erfahrenen kollegen aber
so wie soll das sah ich wollte schon
ruft anklicke kanzleramt hallo angela
sind sie dran so funktioniert das ja
nicht das wissen wir nein das
funktioniert ganz anders da gibt's ein
vorgespräch und der heißt die gerne die
bundeskanzlerin ja ja dem moment hätte
die bundeskanzlerin natürlich ihre
europäischen nachbarn ich war noch nicht
fertig selbst wenn ich das wort
unterstelle telefonat dabei
aber genauso läuft ja der luca del beruf
an merkel also ein so läuft das natur
genau dort angemeldet dann genau will
ich ja anrufen usw
selbst wenn ich das in rechnung stelle
dass es hier darum geht die flüchtlinge
zurück zu transportieren dass man da
hilft und so weiter also irgendwas in
gang zu bringen selbst dann bei abwägung
dieser umstände bin ich dagegen dass die
kanzlerin mit diesem mann redet diesen
mann muss man isolieren mit dem darf
überhaupt niemand reden und natürlich
gibt es diplomatische kontakte auf
unterer ebene und wenn der mann von den
vereinten nationen vom
flüchtlingshilfswerk hilfe haben möchte
um die flüchtlinge zurück zu bringen
soll er sich doch bitte sehr das
flüchtlingshilfswerk wenden das hat
natürlich auch putin führen natürlich
auch putin hintergrund ich bin
jedenfalls jetzt nach abwägung deine
these okay also
man hat die gewissen haken die jetzt
gerade in der argumentation
genommen schon bemerkt also man kann
doch mal hin und her abwehrleistung
ergebnis wir haben eine brutale krise an
der außengrenze europas wir brauchen
einen europäischen weg gemeinsam der
leider in den letzten jahren was die
migration
betrifft nicht zum ergebnis geführt hat
wir haben immer noch dasselbe problem
der innenminister hat sich intensiv
eingebracht dieses problem zu lösen
über jahre und es gibt keine europäische
solidarität an dieser stelle zweitens ja
wir brauchen ein europäisch gemeinsames
vorgehen dazu hat auch der außenminister
heiko maas glaube ich sehr gut
eingelassen in dem das man auch
konsequenz nach außen hin zeigt
konsequenz an die die an die eu
außengrenze mit solchen hybriden
auseinandersetzung in kriegs- formen
unterwegs sind so aber trotzdem wir
sprechen von der bundeskanzlerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland eine
erfahrene außenpolitikerin die mit ihrem
stil auch zu reden manche problematik
nicht nur in der migrationsdebatte
gelöst hat ich finde es gut ich weiß
nach meiner kenntnis so hat
regierungssprecher gesagt das ist auch
abgestimmt war mit der europäischen
ebene und mit europäischen partnern dass
dieses telefonat stattfindet es kann in
loser wiedergeben von der
regierungspressekonferenz
unterm strich bleibt wir sprechen nicht
von flüchtlingen
wir sprechen von migranten die im
übrigen auch wahrscheinlich mit allem
was digital möglich ist mit sms terror
mit broschüren an dieser grenze
aufgemacht um den angriff zu stärken so
jetzt kommt ihre klasse genau dein
konsequenz ist es nicht so dass zb was
der regierungssprecher gesagt hat die
bundeskanzlerin mit dem
schenker
gesagt hat wie die humanitären herrn
müller schenkt wie die un hcr mit
material da hinkommt wir kommen jetzt
auf kältere wochen hin ist er ohnehin
eine sehr dramatische situation und ich
glaube das steht auch gut an oder ein
signal zu geben grenzen aufzumachen
aber dort außerhalb europas und an der
außengrenze für eine lösung zu sorgen
wir sind schon einen treffer deswegen
war das gespräch von der bundeskanzlerin
dort hohen hcr und verschiedene
institutionen die auch schon in der
syrien krise eingesetzt wurden von der
weltgemeinschaft um dort humanitär zu
helfen warum kann die uhren hatte er das
nicht direkt mit herrn lukaschenko
besprechen warum das war merkel ja
wirklich ernst meinen oder von der uhr
an dicht haben anderes in not weil er
die leute nicht nach polen los wird die
sind die man der grenze er hat aber es
gehört isoliert sich immer weiter der
flugverkehr nach belarus ist fast zum
erliegen gekommen er ist in großer not
ihm jetzt deshalb wenig na klar dass
angefangen natürlich sagen das ist nicht
schuldige ist dass diese schule linien
die das unterstützen mit sanktionen
belegt sehr richtig und hab dann muss
man das ich finde die sanktionen noch
eher zu ziehen statt ihm die hand zu
reichen also eins ist klar dass
diktatoren wie lukaschenko und auch
putin januar auf druck reagiere nur auf
druck auf druck auf druck und auch
nichts anderes kann hören ist nicht wohl
als auch in der strategie sein und nicht
diese entweder ohne punkt ist nicht dass
sich die bundeskanzlei unterhalten hat
der punkt ist dass sie andere länder
offenbar übergangen hat und das ist
deswegen massiven ärger gab denn wir
sehen wir sind nicht das front land das
in polen beispielsweise die bayerischen
staaten die haben das kernproblem dass
sie ihre grenzen außengrenzen im osten
mit ländern haben die alles anreist
demokratischen und das ist das
kernproblem schäfer als deutsche sommer
vielleicht doch ein bisschen
selbstbewusstsein was wir zum
europäischen prozess beitragen können
eine bundeskanzlerin die 16 jahre für
europa als überzeugte europäerin gewirkt
hat hat und wir waren alle nicht bei dem
gespräch dabei doch auch die möglichkeit
zum einen zu sagen was sind
beispielsweise die humanitären
möglichkeiten die wir mit den
internationalen organisationen haben um
zum anderen vielleicht war das auch
gegenstand des gesprächs zu sagen wenn
du das nicht auflöst wirst du mit noch
stärkeren und härteren sanktionen zu
viele außer frage diese migranten
wollten ihre übrigen nicht nach europa
das wollten sie nicht nur in hall
deutschland und sie haben das an der
grenze aufgerufen richtig und deshalb
finde ich es doppelt unangenehm dass
dann die bundeskanzlerin dieses landes
auch noch bei dem diktator der sie mit
diesem ruf losgeschickt hat anruft und
fragt kann ich behilflich sein das
problem zu lösen
da wir bei dem gespräch nicht dabei
waren ich vertraue auf die
außenpolitische kompetenz der
bundeskanzlerin und die wird die
richtige entscheidung darüber aus ihrer
erfahrung heraus gemacht haben auch
abgestimmt so die aussage des
regierungssprechers mit den europäischen
partnern und ich würde mal sagen
reden ist vielleicht an manchen stellen
auch wenn es andere systeme sind keine
demokratischen systeme feinde europas
vielleicht sogar eine möglichkeit solche
prekären situationen und da haben wir
noch keinen schneefall gehabt aufzulösen